we are getting a look at the most
dangerous toys watch out for toxic toys
keep these fidgets spinners away from
kids are you sick of being warned about
anything and everything when it comes to
the holiday season me too that's why I'm
ready to throw an icicle at a group
called world against toys causing harm
or watch every year since 1973 it's
published a paranoid list of the ten
worst toys at Christmastime anything
that could make your child sick anything
that could endanger your child's health
just because it's popular does not mean
it's safe maybe these warnings were
necessary back in 1973 when companies
were still selling toy ovens that could
smelt or and chemistry sets that could
actually blow people up in fact the toy
world was littered with some bad ideas
from the Cabbage Patch Kid dolls with
mechanical jaws that chewed everything
and including chunks of hair off of kids
heads to lawn darts those sharp metal
things you would toss at your friend's
toes that caused over six thousand
injuries these items were all banned by
the Consumer Product Safety Commission
but today's toys are so incredibly safe
there's almost nothing left to warn
about still the warnings ball is fastest
cookie crumbs into Santa's beard this
fairy one which has easily come off it's
this zero tolerance for risk that watch
and other consumer groups exploit every
Christmas among their top ten dangers
this year are the popular fidget
spinners watches warning is based on
recent reports of children in Oregon and
Texas having gone to the hospital after
choking on broken fidgets spinner pieces
it's probably more chance of a killing
off of a bike then choking on a fidgets
spinner also on this year's list is the
Wonder Woman battle action sword which
the watch team says encourages young
children to bear arms as if you get a
Wonder Woman toy and immediately deploy
to Yemen they also say that the rigid
plastic sword blade has the potential to
cause facial or other impact injuries
yeah but so does a fork in fact so does
a candy cane if you suck it to a sharp
point so much for female empowerment
and even this innocent-looking
disney-themed plush toy didn't escape
watches notice the group warns that the
toy could be dangerous because of fabric
hats and bows that can detach posing a
choking hazard that's a lot of goods
especially considering the Consumer
Product Safety Commission notes on its
own website that its head
let's count zero reports of injuries the
toy Association a trade group says
watches dangerous toys list is an
exercise in pointless panic it's obvious
the toys that explode and toys that are
just plain dumb like boomerang paid out
a razor blades those are bad but if it
only worked a little harder all that
watch could stop kids from ever playing
with any toys again so if you want a
really great gift for kids how about
they wake up Christmas morning unwrap
the giant package under the tree had
find their very own planet liability
lawyer wind him up and watch him sue all
the other toys hours of fun and then
when the kids get bored they lock him in
the toy chest and go play with a great
toy a stick
you
you